Hollywood joins the call for change in
America we have now reached one full
week of protests that are spread all
over the world and so many famous faces
have hit the streets and social media to
show their support we need justice for
George Floyd when I talking about why
we're witnessing what we're witnessing
and that reason is because another man
died at the hands of police officer I've
done videos against police brutality I
feel like this is like my seventh time
people are it's harder than what do we
do because burning stuff down doesn't
seem to be there the answer when we see
you guys out here on the front line
we won't unless you know you got support
Jamie Foxx rallied protesters in
Minneapolis just a few miles from where
Nick Cannon visited the street where
George Floyd died ariana grande wore a
mask in March for hours in LA Shawn
Mendes and girlfriend Camila caballo hit
the streets of Miami meanwhile a
frightening night for actor John Cusack
in Chicago he was confronted by police
he tweeted cops didn't like me filming
the burning car so they came at me with
batons hitting my bike and he released
this video in Santa Monica Halsey says
she was hit twice by rubber bullets and
tear gassed she shared this pic of a
bruise and video from the protests after
Kendrick Samson from insecure was
protesting and live on his Instagram
when he was hit by rubber bullets
meanwhile journal is covering the
protests are under fire we just got hit
by tear gas Fox News correspondent
Leland Vitter
was hounded by protesters as he reported
from outside the White House early
Saturday morning as we were being pushed
we sort of pushed our way forward he
just wouldn't stop walking and
eventually after about two blocks got to
a police car will you go back out there
absolutely and you have to and my my job
is to try and give our viewers the best
information and the Rost version of
what's happening in order to do that
you've got to hear from the people who
are in those situations and who are
angry enough to be on the street
meanwhile in Minneapolis tear gas being
shot CNN's Sara Seidner has been on the
scene since the protests erupted sir
in this situation coming off of Cove in
nineteen all of a sudden you're on a
plane and you're in the middle of this
how hard is that added element been it's
always about trying to get the people's
voices out there and the best story
there was a moment yesterday where for
the first time you connected the Floyd
family with the police chief
the ployed family has asked if you are
going to get justice for George Floyd
when I told her it was the Floyd family
asking these questions through me
he took his cattle and this is civil if
I marry now this is the Floyd family
after that interview I could not contain
myself and that kind of respect and
compassion is a rare thing right now and
it broke me down
Sara and all the reporters have done
such an amazing job in the field and we
want them to stay healthy and safe
[Music]